plus important, c'est qu'on vous amène
des solutions que vous n'avez pas. Et
quand on a commencé à décortiquer ce
genre de choses, on s'est rendu compte
qu'effectivement l'art de la nouvelle
guerre économique, c'était un surtout de
ne pas apparaître comme un concurrent, 2
en aucun cas d'être agressif, 3 de ne
pas être perçu comme quelqu'un qui
déstabilise des choses qui existent sur
place. Euh quatre de se faire des
copains au niveau local, de commencer à
tisser des liens. La fondation
Rockfeller qui est une excellente
fondation, n'hésite pas à verser des
salaires de gens qui sont pas américains
et qui bossent dans ce réseau-là et
cetera.
Travail mérite salaire
et absolument tout ça tout ça n'est
qu'évidence et logique mais on voit un
art de la guerre excellent. Alors
justement gen
21e siècle qu'est-
21e siècle je me dis mais en France on a
un truc génial ça s'appelle la
protection civile la sécurité civile
les pompiers français forment je ne sais
combien de pompiers à l'étranger on a on
avait des entreprises qui fabriquaient
du matériel destin à la production
civile et cetera et je me dis mais
comment se fait-il qu'en France on ne
fait pas la même chose c'estàd il y a
pas une tasse forte force qui se crée,
qui réunit les différents parties
prenantes dans ce monde-là. On market le
concept et comme on n'est pas mauvais et
comme on est même parfois plus efficace
que d'autres pour rétablir le courant
par exemple puisque ça englobe tout le
système de résilience là,
faisons-le. Et ben on le fait pas. Ou
alors pire pire les Chinois viennent au
contact disent votre système nous
intéresse. On envoie une délégation en
Chine et là qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Les
chefs d'entreprise français qui sont
concurrents sur des modes de matériel se
déchirent la tête devant les Chinois et
qui remporte le marché des camions pour
lutter contre incendie. les Allemands.
Donc là, il y a un problème. Il y a un
vrai problème. C'est-à-dire que quand on
est devant des démonstration aussi
évidente, ça veut dire qu'effectivement
la guerre cognitive
1, on a toujours pas compris ce que
c'était de on n'est toujours pas capable
de la mettre en avant et de la créer
sur les populations. Ça donne quoi la
guerre cognitive ? Alors déjà, pourquoi
ça prend ? Est-ce que c'est parce que
notre système éducatif
est sous pression ? Est-ce que ça prend
parce que nos journalistes se font
prendre un peu à faire le ménage à
gauche à droite et puis à faire le
ménage pour des puissances étrangères à
gauche à droite. Est-ce que la
population qui perd confiance dans ces
institutions,
c'est pas un terrain propice
en à toutes les propagandes à à laisser
notre population civile au quatre vents
de toutes les propagandes ? Si et
aucun effort n'est fait pour remédier à
ça.
Il y a des fact checkers.
Oui oui oui. Mais c'est un problème
systémique en fait. Moi je me souviens
d'une réunion qui m'a marqué dans ma
vie. J'ai dit j'ai eu plusieurs vies. Un
jour au début des années 80 je
travaillais pour un magazine qui
s'appelait Antenne qui était financé par
la Ligue de l'enseignement et je me
retrouve ça portait sur la télévision et
je me retrouve devant le comité exécutif
de la ligue de Ruré Camille. C'était à
l'époque
la plus grosse structure associative
française plus plusieurs je sais plus
30000 associations. C'est énorme. Et on
aborde un sujet à un moment donné qui
est l'introduction de l'informatique à
l'école.
Et là qu'est-ce que j'ai vu ? J'ai vu en
face de moi des gens mais qui voulaient
pas entendre parler de ça parce que
comment on allait faire
alors que tous les territoires étaient
déjà bien posés, le français,
l'histoire, les matchs ont passé les
meilleurs sur l'ensemble. Il y a pas de
territoire pour ça. Mais créer un
territoire pour ça, mais ou là là, c'est
remettre en question tout le système.
Quand
20 ans plus tard, un Indien qui vient de
l'épita et qui fait l'école de guerre
économique,
l'épita, c'est bien.
Bah, il a il a il a la double culture en
plus. Il me dit "Mais tu sais, Christian
comment s'est passé en Inde ?" B J'ai
dit "Non, je ne sais pas.
Le politique indien un jour a dit
notre programme d'enseignement au niveau
des collèges et surtout des lycées, on
va le modifier pendant un certain temps
pour mettre de côté certaines matières,
certains territoires cognitifs
au profit des maates et de l'initiation
au codage informatique élémentaire et
des choses comme ça. décision politique,
acceptation
du système d'enseignement indien. Le
résultat de ça, on le voit aujourd'hui.
Il y a des universités, il y a des
ingénieurs informatiques et l'Inde s'est
positionné de manière très intéressante
dans ce qu'on appelle le marché de
l'informatique.
Imaginons qu'en France, un pouvoir
politique dise au ministres de
l'éducation nationale, à ses inspecteurs
généraux et à tout ce qui est en
dessous.
Parce qu'on considère que c'est une
priorité nationale de développer
l'économie numérique, on va mettre en
sommeil telle et telle matière pendant
15 ans et on va mettre la priorité
maximale sur telle ou telle autre
matière. On
a pas de budget
et puis c'est même pas pensable.
On a pas de budget,
c'est
on a pas le temps.
On n pas le temps.
On a pas de budget et surtout parce que
c'est ça le problème, comment va réagir
le corps enseignant ? Faut pas l'oublier
ce corps enseignant, il fait ce qu'il
peut
souffre qui souffre déjà. Il souffrent
énormément,
on le sait, mais
on fait pas grand-chose.
On les laisse souffrir.
On les laisse souffrir et on leur t pas
la main pour leur donner des pistes sans
les traumatiser.
Et là, oui, il faut du jus de cerveau.
Là, les fameux inspecteurs généraux qui
pour l'instant hélas participent à
l'effondrement global du système
éducatif selon vous,
c'est mon avis parce que moi je l'ai moi
je réceptionne des étudiants au bac + 4
et 5 et je vois comment il faut
rattraper un certain nombre de choses et
ce que je remarque c'est que il n'y a
pas d'envie
intellectuelle j'ai employé un adjectif
au combien ambitieux pour se dire je ne
suis pas là simplement pour sauver
ces jeunes d'une détresse sociale. Je
suis là aussi pour contribuer à créer un
système qui va permettre à une économie
de se développer de manière à ce que ces
jeunes trouve un job, de manière à ce
que ces jeunes soient dans une économie
plus dynamique, de manière à ce qu'on
trace des pistes que moi enseignant je
contribue à aider à ma modeste mesure
cette nouvelle dynamique créative.
Il y a pas
comment on fait pour endurcir une
population
on va prendre l'exemple des Français.
Comment on fait pour endurcir les
Français ? Comment on fait pour quand il
y a une opération qui est dirigée depuis
l'extérieur pour influencer notre
population pour aller dans un sens d'un
vote ou dans un sens d'un autre vote ou
pour être contestataire sur un sujet
énergétique ou un autre sujet
énergétique ? Comment on fait pour les
endurcir
au jour d'aujourd'hui ? Alors si on peut
je vais prendre un exemple.
L'agriculture
l'énergie. Non, celui-là je pourrais le
prendre parce qu'on a amené notre petite
pierre de touche sur un dossier qui
s'appelait j'attaque et en tapant sur
mais c'est quoi l'Allemagne ? Pourquoi
elle nous a fait du mal comme ça ?
D'accord. Pourquoi elle nous a
déstabilisé à ce point ?
Vous avez des preuves de ça ? Bah, on a
fait un dossier qui est une grille de
lecture avec des logiques de
démonstration avec les sources, les
références, on a rien inventé. On a
simplement reconstitué un puzzle que
finalement personne n'avait voulu
vraiment réaliser. Et là, on a dit voilà
le problème.
Attention avec ceux qui construisent des
puzzles parce que des fois ils ont leur
propre biais cognitif.
On est d'accord.
On est d'accord. Nonnêtement, l'objectif
c'était simplement de d'essayer de
mettre à plat les différents aspects du
problème, pas simplement un ou deux,
mais l'ensemble. Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec cet ensemble ? Comment on l'analyse
? Donc si je reviens à l'agriculture,
l'exemple, on voit arriver
des nouveaux entrants dans le monde
agricole qui disent "On va sauver
l'humanité pour la nourrir." Alors, ils
ont 2050 parce que les filières
traditionnelles elles pourront pas le
faire.
Et on voit arriver là deux types
d'acteurs,
les gens de la silicone vallée et des
gens de l'agroalimentaire américain. Et
ces gens-là, qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ?
Ils disent
"Faisons de l'agriculture cellulaire,
faisons de la viande artificielle,
allons sur ces terrainslà d'abord
et là il s'adresse au financiers. Vous
n'aurez pas les problèmes de débat sur
la vie des animaux, les conditions
d'élevage et cetera et cetera.
Le CO2,
le CO2 et cetera. Là, on fait de mal à
personne, disent-il et on va fabriquer
de l'alimentation. Petit détail, alors
on s'est penché sur cette question là et
j'ai constaté que le monde agricole
français au début ne réagissait pas.
La filière viande,
elle se vivait dans son propre univers
et jusqu'au moment où ils ont commencer
à comprendre qu'elle était menacée
de disparition à terme
et à partir de ce moment-là sur quoi on
a travaillé ? Mais au fait cette
histoire d'agriculture cellulaire où
devient l'artificiel quand il y a eu les
OGM, il y a quelqu'un qui a levé le
doigt qui s'appelait José Bosé qui a dit
s'adressait au président de l'Académie
des Sciences une émission célèbre de la
télévision monsieur vous êtes un
scientifique
pouvez-vous me certifier que ça ne
rendra pas malade les EGM ? et en bon
scientifique, l'homme a répondu "Mais
non, je peux pas vous je peux pas vous
le certifier. Il y a toujours une marge
d'incertitude.
De cette absence de réponse là est née
une contestation groupaire anti OGM qui
a été une des plus belles guerres de
l'information réussie par des acteurs de
la société civile en étant une toute
petite force." ce qui a abouti au
résultats des OGM aujourd'hui au niveau
de l'Europe
qui qui est
et ben c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on
peut pas mener une agriculture à base de
GM. En revanche en revanche on importe
énormément de viande venant d'ailleurs
élevé à base de GM et on la consomme. Ça
dérange personne. OK belle
contradiction. Mais si j'en viens à
l'agriculture cellulaire, moi je pose
une question. Vous pouvez me dire si ça
rend ça va rendre malade ou pas ? La
même question. Bah
avec les OGM, on voit pas trop de malade
quand même. Mais il y en a Non, c'est
mais justement c'est ça qui est
intéressant.
C'est-à-dire qu'au moment où a été
déclenché l'attaque contre les EGM
dans l'industrie pharmaceutique, on
commençait à produire de plus en plus de
médicaments à base d'GM. Donc s'il y
avait vraiment eu une guerre de
l'information à l'époque, c'était de
dire d'un côté vous demandez si ça rend
malade quand on consomme de
l'alimentation à base de GM et de
l'autre ça soigne. Si je caricature.
Alors comment on fait là ? Sauf que sauf
que cette guerre de l'information n'a
pas eu lieu. Je me souviens d'un homme
qui s'appelait Pierre Pagès qui
dirigeait le groupe Limagrin et qui
était confronté à ça puisqu'on lui
fauchait ses champs. Enfin, il était
confronté à des attaques
informationnelles assez précises.
Il n'a pas pu réagir à ce problème.
Pourquoi ? Parce que l'industrie
pharmaceutique ne voulait en aucun cas
être associé à la polémique qui était en
train de
naître. J'ouvre une parenthèse pour
défendre les faucheurs quand même. Il y
avait pas que ça. Il y avait aussi le
fait que le pollen pouvait aller se
balader. Il y avait On est bien d'accord
que c'est un vrai débat. Mais pour moi,
si on va jusqu'au bout du débat,
si je me mets dans le camp des
faucheurs, OK, avec mon action, je
contribue à interdire les expériences et
les cultures à base de GM. Mais dans ce
cas-là, les camions qui transportent de
la viande
qui vient d'élevage à base de GM élevé à
l'étranger, pourquoi je les bloque pas ?
Pourquoi on a cette hypocrisie
incroyable que toute une partie de la
viande consommée en France est à base de
GM ? Viande importée ?
Mais vous vos vos chiffres ? Ça vient
d'où
les chiffres ? Ça, je peux vous
renvoyer une étude qu'on a fait sur ce
sujet-là. l' envoyer à notre communauté.
Mais je vous l'envoie. Non, non, mais
c'est vous avez raison de me le
signaler, j'ai pas le chiffre en tête
mais on a travaillé sur cette question
et on voit bien qu'il y avait un
véritable problème de déséquilibre dans
le débat. Là, je parle simplement de
comment poser le débat. C'estàdire si on
va jusqu'au bout, on interdit la viande
d'élevage à base de GM. Peu importe
d'ailleurs à la limite l'amplitude du
phénomène.
À l'heure actuelle, nous sommes en
guerre à 3h de vol de Paris.
Ouis.
Quel regard vous portez sur la guerre
informationnelle, que ce soit la guerre
information qui vient des Russes, la
guerre informationnelle qui vient de
l'Ukraine, la guerre informationnelle
qui vient de l'OTAN, la guerre
informationnelle de tout le monde ? On
se rappelle au début de la guerre, l'île
du serpent et puis après il y a pas eu
l'île de serpent et ainsi de suite. Ça
continue des des deux côtés. C'est juste
de la propagande de guerre comme à comme
à la propagande de guerre la papa alors
qu'il y a des milliers de morts de
chaque côté euh des dizaines de milliers
de morts de chaque côté des populations
déplacées des gamins à la rue sans toit
sans maison des animaux de compagnie
largués
en veux-tu en voilà quel regard vous
vous portez sur ce qui se passe ? Alors,
on a commencé sur un plan très pratique,
c'est-à-dire que dès le début de la
guerre, il y a à le à l'école de guerre
économique, il y a ce qu'on appelle un
club qui fait de l'occine, donc la
recherche d'information
en source ouverte.
En source ouverte uniquement, je
précise. Et ce groupe d'étudiants a
commencé mais vraiment dès le début à
regarder ce qui passait sur internet, à
regarder tout ce qui était émis en
images, en micro et cetera et cetera.
Sur quel canon ?
sur les canaux disponibles de l'époque.
Et c'est vrai qu'à ce moment-là,
ce petit groupe d'étudiants a travaillé
avec Tielmans Ré Cosmos et a réalisé un
certain nombre de travaux
qui avaient une valeur, je pense,
relativement démonstrative. Ce qui est
étonné à l'époque d'ailleurs, c'est
pourquoi on on a réagi aussi vite. C'est
vrai que là, on a réagi et on était au
bon niveau du tempo.
On a continué aussi dans la même veine à
essayer d'observer comment
apparaissaient les confrontations,
c'estàdire ceux qui commentaient ce qui
se passait.
Et on voyait des choses assez basiques
d'ailleurs hein. Franchement
un des points faibles à l'époque à
l'époque de ceux qui étaient ou qu'on
qualifie de prorusse. C'était qu'il ne
faisait jamais de critique sur ce qui se
passait côté russe. Ça la ficelle est
grosse quand même et c'est un point
faible.
Euh côté ukrainien,
on pouvait s'interroger à l'époque
pourquoi il y a pas eu d'image sur la
fameuse prise de l'aéroport, l'échec de
ce coût militaire pour aller sur Kief et
comment l'image était traitée côté
ukrainien. C'est-à-dire, il nous a
semblé que euh alors est-ce que c'était
de la pudeur de pas montrer des corps de
soldats russes qui avaient été
certainement. Il y avait certainement ça
parce que ça fait partie de la
complexité de deux peuples qui
s'affrontent et qui sont en même temps
quand même relativement proche pour 1000
1000 raisons. Mais on s'est rendu compte
que vite euh il allait falloir vraiment
faire la part des choses entre les deux
systèmes
de guerre de l'information qui était en
train de se développer.
Je note que depuis peu la
vice-présidente des États-Unis pour la
première fois a pris la parole sur elle
a appeler ça des crimes de guerre contre
l'humanité sur
des faits commis par des troupes russes
sur territoire ukrainien.
C'est beaucoup de temps pour prendre la
parole sur un sujet pareil. C'estàd que
ça aussi ça nous a interpellé. Il faut
le temps qu'ils enquêtent, il faut aller
sur le terrain collecter les preuves.
Absolument.
On est dans une situation tendue. Si on
voit les États-Unis débarquer sur ça,
ils se plante. Ils ont pas les bonnes
preuves. C'est normal qu'il v
d'accord. On est d'accord. Mais quand on
voit ce que les Américains sont capables
et quand on connaît leur force de frappe
informationnelle, tout vecteur confondu,
là je parle pas simplement du
département d'État ou de tout ce qui est
affilié aux autorités fédérales. Je vois
pas de rouleau compresseur venir des
États-Unis pour dire ce problème-là
c'est un problème majeur et on fait
dessus vers les sociétés civiles avec
tous les vecteurs possibles. On en fait
un vrai sujet. J'ai entendu un discours.
Point. Et ça se limite à ça. Donc
pourquoi je mets ça en avant ? parce que
en progressant dans la guerre, on se
rend compte que
il y a une manière de mener la guerre de
l'information,
que ce soit du côté ukrainien ou que ce
soit du côté russe qui est
qui exige une analyse beaucoup plus
pointue que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui.
On a quand même plein d'experts super
pointus.
Oui, en principe, mais pas tant que ça.
Les experts super pointus, Oui, moi je
le jour où la guerre a commencé, j'avais
une réunion avec le général Jean-Claude
Galet sur un autre sujet et qui me dit
"On était le jour du déclenchement de
l'attaque. Si les Russes n'arrivent pas
à aller chercher Zelinski dans les 48
heures à Kief,
c'est le début de l'enlisement de leur
opération. Et il avait raison. Et Galet,
je pense à largement euh
le cheminement professionnel et la
compétence pour avoir dit ça. C'était un
militaire français. Il n'était plus en
activité. C'est le directeur de sécurité
de Michelin aujourd'hui. Mais il avait
raison. D'accord. Mais dans l'époque
actuelle, à quoi on est confronté ? On
est confronté à différentes guerres de
l'information. La première, là où les
Russes sont pas au maximum de ce qu'il
pourrait faire, c'est que
c'est quoi le maximum ?
Bah c'est que les gens commencent à les
croire au premier degré. Et quand on dit
à qui profite la guerre sur le plan
économique,
c'est pas très compliqué de constater
que pour l'instant c'est les États-Unis
d'Amérique, c'est pas l'Europe. Les
Russes pourraient taper très très dur
là-dessus. Finalement, ils le font pas
tant que ça. C'est intéressant
d'ailleurs. Et on peut se poser la
question pourquoi ils ne le font pas
plus que ça ? Peut-être que vous l'avez
pas vu.
Alors, peut-être que je l'ai pas vu.
C'est vrai. C'est vrai. Mais moi,
j'observe surtout ce qu'on écoute et ce
qui est dit ici. C'estd pars du
périmètre informationnel France voire un
peu plus. Et là, je constate que on a
une faille parce que quand j'observe
ce qui se dit côté prourainien en France
notamment sur ce sujet-là,
il y a pas un mot. C'estàd ça peut être
considéré comme une faille, comme un
point faible. Et comment on argumente ?
Comment on le contre ? Rien. Zéro
discours. C'est un effort de guerre
économique aussi.
Mais là, on va sur un deuxième terrain.
C'est la question que vous me posiez au
tout début.
Pourquoi on n pas vu la guerre
économique ? Alors là, je suis obligé de
réouvrir un tiroir d'une ancienne vie.
Au début des années 90,
il y avait des gens qui ont publié même
dans les années 80, excusez-moi,
les fameux soviétologues.
Euh je sais pas si des soviétologues,
mais je me souviens des cris émanents à
l'époque du secrétariat général de la
défense nationale où il était dit la
guerre économique ça n'existe pas. Ça
existe dans le cas d'un conflit
militaire mais en situation de paix,
c'est un faux concept. Donc si vous
voulez quand dans au moment au moment où
Ronald Rigan
déclencher une guerre économique du
temps de paix vers les Russes pour leur
couper l'approvisionnement en céréales
puisque les Russes importaient
énormément de céréales américaines pour
nourrir la population et là les
Américains, ils étaient aux manettes
pour créer le maximum de troupes
possibles en en Russie par des besoins
non satisfaits sur les besoins vitaux
alimentémentaires. la population se
nourrir. Donc
moi, ça fait quand même pas mal d'années
que je travaille sur ce sujet là, le
parcours du combattant pour essayer de
faire comprendre que la guerre
économique, c'est pas un fantasme, c'est
pas un délire de je ne sais quoi, mais
c'est une réalité, mais c'est un
parcours du combattant qui a duré 30
ans. 30 ans. Et heureusement qui est
arrivé non pas le sauveur,
mais il a fallu attendre monsieur Donald
Trump, président des États-Unis, pour
ouvrir les volets et dire
voilà ce que c'est la guerre économique
entre la Chine et les États-Unis. Et là
euh
gros tremblement de terre échelle 8 sur
l'échelle de Richelle. C'est ça.
Comment on va faire ? Le président des
États-Unis d'Amérique reconnaît
officiellement qu'il y a un affrontement
entre deux puissances
qu'on croyait limité au problèmes de
territoire. le Tibet, les revendications
en en en mer en du côté de de la Chine
et et et les fameux atoles euh le la
fameuse ligne en en sep points en en
point j'ai un trou de mémoire.
Bref, des aspects géopolitiques, des
aspects géographiques.
La question de Taïwan et quoi que des
quoi qu'à l'époque, elle était largement
en sommeil,
on le problème d'Hong Kong était déjà
présent lui et
en fait toute cette réalité là,
il y avait pas un mot sur la guerre
économique avant Trump. Et il y avait
pas mais mais c'est pas vrai. Robert
Guillaume ?
Ah
le petit Robert.
Je vous parle pas du grand
Oui, je vous parle pas de la petite
communauté d'intelligence économique en
France qui avait travaillé là-dessus.
D'ailleurs à muté d'ailleurs hein, c'est
plus les mêmes
ou oui, on est bien d'accord. mais qui
était euh des enfin traverser le
désert en permanence parce queils
avaient beau mettre sur la table un
certain nombre de réalités de ce type,
on ne voulait pas les entendre, on ne
les écoutait pas, ils n'existent pas.
Il y a des jeux de guerre économiques ou
pas ? Ce qu'on appelle des war games,
les avions et les bateaux. Est-ce qu'il
y a des des war de guerre économique ?
Des jeux de guerre économique ? Est-ce
qu'on anticipe ? On fait des scénarios ?
Est-ce qu'on fait des scénarios ? où on
se dit "Oh bah tiens euh les Russes ils
sont en train de se préparer à sortir
d'Internet.
Bah tiens, ils sont en train de se
préparer à sortir de Swift. Oh bah
tiens, ils sont en train d'accumuler de
l'or depuis des années. Oh bah tiens,
ils ont des nouvelles armes. Oh bah
tiens, c'est comme alors il y a
Bloomberg qui vient de réaliser que
grâce à la guerre en Ukraine, on
comprend que il y a pas beaucoup de pays
qui produisent des engrais. Ah bah
tiens, qu'est-ce qui se passe si les
engrais sont plus bien exportés ou si on
boycotte les engrais ? Qu'est-ce que ça
fait sur le prix de la bouffe ? Est-ce
que ça va créer des soldats zombes
russes dans notre propre territoire ?
Parce que ils en ont marre de
l'inflation, ils en ont marre de tout
ça, ainsi de suite. Est-ce qu'on fait
des jeux de guerre de tout ça ? Est-ce
que tu as déjà entendu ?
Il y avait pas il y avait pas.
Il y avait pas. Alors
non, mais je donne un exemple.
Attends, j'ai pas fini. Je suis désolé,
je parle beaucoup. Ça me fait plaisir
quoi de te voir. OK.
On a résisté à la pandémie.
Ça fait longtemps qu'on s pas vu. Donc
quand quand on voit le collège interarmé
de défense se muter en école de guerre,
on se dit les gars,
on fait des jeux de guerre économique ou
pas ? Est-ce que tu as déjà entendu
parler de ça
ou peut-être que tuas tu as pas le
niveau d'accréditation suffisamment
important ? Ça commence à venir. Ça
commence à venir. Mais attention euh
c'est pas parce que on a la chance
d'avoir un général Bucart qui a compris
ça et quelques personnes qui l'entourent
aussi que l'armée a compris ça.
L'armée, ça fait bien longtemps qu'elle
a compris.
Non non parce que le problème est là. Le
problème est là. C'est-à-dire je donne
un exemple qui quand même est très
significatif. On sait bien que tout le
monde militaire et en particulier en
France est très à l'écoute de ce qui se
passe dans le monde anglo-saxon est très
à l'écoute de ce qui se passe dans le
temps et très à l'écoute dans tout ce
que publie ce monde anglo-saxon au
niveau stratégique, au niveau
géopolitique, au niveau politique
communautaire et cetera.
C'est une guerre cognitive.
Oui, bien sûr que çaen est une. Mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai appris il y a à peine
5 jours ? Kings College de Londres
qui est quand même une des écoles les
plus prestigieuses du Royaume-Uni.
Sorti un papier sur la guerre cognitive
non a créé un laboratoire il y a 1 an.
C'est un professeur canadien qui l'a
créé et qui a dit mais comment ça se
fait il y a que les Français qui
travaillent sur la guerre économique ?
Alors soyons raisonnable.
Ça c'est de l'intoxication parce qu'il y
a pas que les français.
Je parle au niveau académique et
laboratoire de recherche et ce
laboratoire qui est constitué surtout de
gens qui sont dans le milieu militaire
britannique d'ailleurs ou l'économie de
défense euh veut travailler avec l'école
de guerre économique et la Stockholm
School of Economics.
Pourquoi je dis ça ? parce que pour la
première fois, le système fonctionne à
l'envers. C'est-à-dire qu'en France, on
a créé, ça fait 26 ans, nous qu'on
travaille là-dessus à travers une école.
Tu en as pas pondu euh des des trucs
importants, ils sont pas aux manettes
tes tes petits poulins là. Il y en a pas
mal de choses. Oui,
ça ils l'ont ils l'ont étudié et c'est
vrai que et c'est vrai que quand on a
créé le concept d'intelligence
économique dans les années 90 économic
war,
attends attends attends attends Robert
Guillaume Randra César qui était
Bernard Rambertoui oui mais bien entendu
mais là je parle économic world c'estd
est-ce que le concept existait dans le
nom d'Anglxon
non ça veut rien dire à l'époque c'est
ce qu'on nous disait les anglo-saxons
nous disaient qu'est-ce que vous faisz
que de guerre la guerre économique mais
c'est non c'est un faux concept.
Alors pour pas perdre nos auditeurs,
pourquoi c'est important la guerre
économique ? Est-ce que c'est important
parce que un chômeur coûte plus cher
qu'un mort quand on est en guerre
entre autres.
Est-ce que c'est parce que quand on se
fait déboîter notre industrie, ça crée
des chômeurs, donc ça ça affaiblit
d'autant plus le pays ? Pourquoi c'est
important la guerre économique ?
C'est important parce que quand on
regarde ce qui se passe aujourd'hui,
l'affaiblissement de l'économie
française, c'est d'abord une absence
totale de vision stratégique sur la
guerre économique.
C'est-à-dire que on est en train de
redécouvrir, mais il a fallu la pandémie
plus la guerre en Ukraine et ses
conséquences pour découvrir que le monde
c'est pas que le marché quoi, c'est pas
j'invente, je fabrique et je vends et
c'est ça le principal. Ça on on découvre
aujourd'hui, il suffit de les Français,
ils voient bien ce que ça leur coûte
dans leur note d'électricité, ce que ça
leur coûte dans ce qu'il payent au
niveau de l'essence, ce que ça leur
coûte au niveau quand ils vont en
supermarché ou dans des magasins pour
acheter des produits.
Toute cette mutation négative qui
pénalise la vie quotidienne des
Français, c'est pas simplement un
problème d'adaptation et de jeux
financier ou de marché.
Et je je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable où je c'est un effort de guerre
économique qu'on demande à la population
sans leur dire.
Alors oui
ou on leur disant
on leur dit pas.
Bah on leur dit on leur dit il faut
aider les Ukrainiens. C'est c'est un
dommage que la terre. Non non non non.
Attention attention. On va leur dire
exactement cette formule là. Faut aider
les Ukrainiens mais on va pas leur dire
ce que nous on essaie de démontrer
depuis pas mal de temps
qui déstabilise l'économie française sur
le long terme. Les ordres de grandeur.
C'est qui ?
Bah le premier pays quand on a fait un
sondage dans les milieux de
l'intelligence économique.
Lesquel ?
Parce que des milieux de l'intelligence
économique, a on va dire qu'il y a
plusieurs factions.
Alors, c'est ceux qui font du conseil,
c'est ceux qui travaillent au contact
des entreprise.
Et la réponse, ça a été les États-Unis
d'Amérique.
Ça Mais non, c'est pas possible.
Si
mais non.
Ah mais si
mais non,
c'est Ben c'est c'est la réponse qui est
sortie. Et pourquoi les États-Unis ?
C'est encore des prusses ça, non ? Ah
ben évidemment, dès le moment où on dit
ça, c'est terminé.
On passe pour
prorusse ou je ne sais quoi. Mais le
problème le problème c'est que lorsqu'on
regarde ce qui se passe aujourd'hui,
les Américains sont en train de créer un
système de protectionnisme. D'accord, il
l'affiche, il le revendiquent. Nous,
je parle de l'Europe là, qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Et si je commence
à sortir les dossiers les uns après les
autres, on se cache, je vais citer un de
mes intervenants, Nicolas Raville qui
bosse beaucoup là-dessus au niveau de
l'Europe sur
les échanges entre États-Unis et Europe
en disant finalement l'Europe a avait
une position plus forte que les
États-Unis, c'est-à-dire qu'elle avait
un commerce
excédentaire par rapport aux États-Unis.
les États-Unis étaient moins puissant
que l'Europe dans les échanges entre les
États-Unis et l'Europe et on dit mais
tout va bien alors puisqu'on est plus
fort que en matière d'échanges
commerciaux. Non, ça ça c'est un miroir
très déformant parce que quand on
commence à rentrer vraiment dans le dur,
c'est-à-dire la désindustrialisation,
c'est-à-dire l'incapacité à maîtriser le
monde matériel, c'est-à-dire
l'incapacité à gérer sans être dépendant
les technologies de l'information et
tout ce qui en découle.
Je parlais de l'agriculture mais je
pourrais citer beaucoup d'autres
secteurs là.
Là je parle de la France puisque en
l'occurrence il s'agit de la France. On
s'affaiblit
et le problème
pas sortis de Saint-Cir pour avoir
constaté ça.
Oui, c'est évident mais il y a un seul
problème, c'est est-ce que par rapport à
cet affaiblissement,
il existe aujourd'hui au plus haut
niveau de l'État un comité de
stratégique pour dire comment stopper
l'affaiblissement. Je renvoie à
l'exemple classique archi pas connu mais
évident. Quel est le seul personnage du
monde politique français au 20e siècle
qui a dit "On va essayer de réduire
notre dépendance économique par rapport
aux États-Unis d'Amérique ?" Ardonbourg
?
Non, c'est le général de Gaulle.
Ah !
Et le général de Gaulle, qu'est-ce qu'il
a fait ? Il a créé Alfakitaen. Il a créé
des quotas des quotas par rapport au
commerce que les multinationales
américaines avaient en France. Il a
essayé et il a échoué de créer une
industrie informatique parce qu'il là il
a eu face à lui des capitaines
d'industrie français qui ne l'ont pas
suivi et c'était pourtant le général de
Gaulle. Il n'était pas assez puissant
pour lutter contre un milieu économique
français qui s'était déjà mis depuis
longtemps en situation de dépendance
acceptée. On dépend des États-Unis, il
nous assure notre sécurité. Donc on en
perdera le prix et ça marchera comme ça.
Donc notre problème aujourd'hui,
c'est que dans les coulisses, bien sûr
que on n'ose pas reconnaître les choses.
On a mis combien de temps pour oser
lever le doigt en disant le fait que
l'Allemagne
accroisse sa puissance par le biais de
l'économie et que malheureusement ça
peut nous pénaliser.
Et c'est depuis peu de temps qu'on ose
sussurer cette phrase. Et la question
c'est comment on fait pour ne pas
continuer à être affaibli y compris par
l'Allemagne et pas simplement les
États-Unis, la Chine ou d'autres ?
Il faut alors comme comment on fait on
les conseille. Si l'Allemagne se vautre,
il y a l'euro qui se vautre. Il il faut
aider l'Allemagne tout à l'heure.
C'est nos copains les Allemands,
ils nous ont jamais embêté. C'est nos
copains. Ça dépend en quoi
depuis Chira qui coule.
Oui. Non mais là on est dans on est dans
la comédia des Larté. Peut-être
nécessaire. C'est c'est très bien que
Béran tienne la main d'un chancellier
allemand à Verdin avec cette vision très
symbolique.
C'est franchement il fallait le faire.
Mais absolument. Je suis pas du tout
contre ça. Mais il faut quand même avoir
et garder les pieds sur terre.
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas parce qu'on a
des rapprochements au combien
nécessaires. On a assez
on s'est fait endormir, on portait des
lunettes roses, on avait la fleur au
fusil, on avait un petit bandana de IPI,
on allait tous embrasser sur la bouche
avec l'Europe.
Est-ce que Est-ce que Est-ce que où sont
nos nos fins lignées ? Où sont nos
prédateurs ? Où sont nos aigles, nos
buses, nos buzards ? Parce que des
buses, on en voit beaucoup. Mais où sont
où sont nos chouettes ?
On a des alors parlons déjà des
prédateurs au sens conquérant. Il y en
a. Il est évident qu'en France, il y a
des entreprises très offensives, que ce
soit des grandes mais aussi des
moyennes, voire des petites.
À un détail prêt,
nous n'avons jamais en pâque.
Par exemple, un détail prêt, c'est que
l'équipe France, celle qu'on pourrait
voir apparaître en Allemagne, en
Allemagne, je vais répéter tout ce
cette image, mais qui est toujours la
même. C'est-à-dire que quand on met dans
une salle des Allemands qui sont
concurrents mais qui à la fin de la
réunion doivent sortir avec une idée
stratégique commune, il se déchire la
tête pendant toute la durée de la
réunion mais à la fin ils sortent avec
une stratégie commune. Nous le problème
c'est qu'on narrive même pas à les
réunir. C'est un exemple qui moi m'a
marqué dans mon petit périmètre de
l'intelligence économique quand Édouard
Baladur a créé ce fameux compétitiv
comité pour la compétitivité et la
sécurité économique. C'est la seule fois
où un premier ministre français
acceptait de présider une réunion allant
dans le sens que tu dis.
Mais les gens qui étaient à qui on avait
demandé à l'époque de venir, le PDG
d'Elf, il y avait encore elf et
d'autres, mais ils savaient pas pourquoi
ils étaient là.
Mais elf quand même si c'était qui à
l'époque
et ben c'était
c'est le floc
pardon
le floc prigeant.
Non non, c'était c'était pas le floc
prigeant.
C'est juste après.
C'est juste après. Mais il savait pas.
Lui, il était déjà dans la logique
marché. dans la post vision gouienne,
c'est-à-dire je suis elle, je suis une
multinationale,
mon enjeu
c'est de satisfaire le système dans
lequel je suis. Donc un système qui ne
fonctionne que sur des logiques de
rentabilité financière et de réussir un
business model et un business plan et
tout ce qui va avec.
Ce comité hélas, c'était une très bonne
idée, mais encore fallait-il que les
gens qui composent ce comité
aille dans une direction et mettre au
moins quelques idées qui allaient
permettre au premier ministre de
l'époque d'avancer
et d'être dans des logiques.
Mais pour aller dans cette direction,
il faut avoir un prisme de lecture
perçant.
Il faut avoir de la prospective, il faut
avoir un bon diagnostic. Est-ce que ce
diagnostic est fait ? Quand on voit des
petits des des petites chinoises se
balader près de nos nos bases de
sous-marin, se marier à gauche à droite,
quand on voit quand on voit des
Américains financer des Simtanks ou
quand on voit des Russes financer des
des ONG ou des dirigeants allemands,
quand on voit tout ça, c'est on avait on
a plus d'oreilles, on a plus d'antennes,
on a jamais voulu, on était feignant, on
était quoi ? On était, on voulait pas
s'atteler à la chose ou est-ce que on
était déjà tellement vérolé qu'on nous a
caressé dans le sens du poil pour éviter
que nos buses, nos buzards, nos aigles
et nos chouettes se restent bien
endormis.
Il y a eu quelques moments où on s'est
réveillé,
rappelons-nous. Là, on est dans la
science-fiction, mais dans les années
80, la DGSE avait un réseau d'espionnage
sur le territoire américain assez
important et avec là des objectifs très
très précis sur l'industrie informatique
qui a été démantelé parce que
semble-t-il, si je crois le journaliste
de l'Express qui a traité ce sujet-là et
on peut retrouver ces articles sur
internet d'ailleurs, il y a quelqu'un
qui a eu des états d'âmes à Paris parce
qu'on espionnait un pays allié.
Et c'était à l'époque où Pierre Marion
était le premier patron de la DGSE
avant, c'était le SDEC et donc on changé
de de nom mais
et d'époque
et d'époque bien sûr
lorsqu'il y a eu la révélation de ce
réseau qui était important, il y avait
plusieurs dizaines de cadres
d'entreprises françaises avec leurs
filiales ou qui travaillaient aux
États-Unis qui renseignait ce réseau,
c'était vraiment une véritable démarche
offensive
Après, c'était terminé.
Il était hors de question de recommencer
une histoire comme ça.
D'accord. Mais quand nous on a appris
grâce à Edward Snowden que nos boîtes,
nos présidents, les les contrats qui qui
dépassaient un certain nombre de
milliers de dollars tout de suite
étaient sous le regard de la NSA. Est-ce
qu'on s'est un petit peu énervé ? Est-ce
que toi dans ton école, tu as des
services qui sont passés en disant voilà
bon pop, il va nous falloir nous affuter
tout ça. Est-ce que est-ce que tu
participes au recrutement de certains
pour nos services, pour notre état ?
Est-ce qu' ils sont venus te voir en
disant bon,
OK, maintenant faut s'affuter un peu là.
Ça s'est pas passé comme ça. Qu'on
participe au recrutement. Oui, ça c'est
vrai.
Peut-être la DGSE ou les Chinois.
Non. Oui. Non mais de toute façon,
hélas, il y a différents types de public
qui arrive.
Non mais ce qui est vrai, c'est que on a
3000 anciens aujourd'hui. C'est pas
énorme mais c'est déjà un petit nombre.
Et sur les 3000, il y en a au moins 200
voire 300 qui ont travaillé ou qui
travaillent dans les services de
renseignement et de sécurité français,
ce qui est déjà une proportion
intéressante. Et là, il y a eu un début
de 109 mais c'est pas les services qui
sont venus nous voir en disant "Allez-y
les gars, il y a un programme à créer
là. On a créé un un programme éminance.
C'est la première fois qu'on sort un peu
du cadre intelligence économique, source
ouverte et qu'on essaie de voir côté
renseignement comment les deux se
combinent. Euh personne nous a demandé
de le faire. On s'est automissionné pour
le faire. La plupart de des éléments
créatifs de l'GE,
c'est de l'automission.
Et ben alors, c'est très français ça
l'automission.
Ah mais complètement. Mais complètement.
Mais c'est vrai et ça c'est plutôt une
bonne chose d'ailleurs parce que
l'automission c'est la créativité et la
grande force de l'école de guerre
économique c'est qu'on a eu cette chance
extraordinaire qu'on nous laisse créer.
Et là, je remercie aussi bien monsieur
Joseph qui nous a accueilli dans ses
locaux à Leselska, mais je remercie
aussi bien y compris le groupe planéta
actuel qui est le propriétaire de l'GE
et qui continue à nous laisser créer.
Là, on est presque de nouveau dans
Xfille au bon sens du terme. Nous ne
sommes pas entravés en terme de
créativité. Qui peut prétendre ça en
France aujourd'hui ? C'est notre chance.
On dit on dit que le renseignement c'est
alors il faut que je retrouve la phrase
exacte. Vous me corrigerez si je me
plante. Euh c'est un domaine de roi fait
par des truants.
Ouais. Et les profils pour rentrer à
l'Est-ce
que est-ce que tu arrives à détecter les
gamins qui pensent en dehors de la boîte
mais pas pas perché ? Oui oui oui oui.
Des gamins qui pensent patriotisme,
défense du territoire, défense de nos
entreprises et donc défense de notre
souveraineté.
Alors la vocation de le G au départ
c'était ça.
C'est pour ça qu'on nous a regardé très
bizarrement parce qu'on s'est mis on
sait qui on sait les petits cercles
d'intelligence économique qui étaient
sur des salons feutrés à s'échanger des
petites cartes et et à se mettre en
groupe sur Twitter. Bah non, c'était
alors là je rends à César ce qui revient
à César. C'est trois généraux
qui n'était plus en activité mais qui
étaient toujours
bien présent dans cette dynamique là.
Donc je les cite parce que c'est
important.
le général Mermé,
le général Pichot du Clot avec qui j'ai
créé l'école de guerre économique,
Mermit dirigé la DGSE, Pichot du Clot
avait son dernier temps de commandement,
c'était l'école interarmée du
renseignement et études linguistiqu et
un homme qui n'apparaît pas comme tel
mais qui a joué un rôle énorme dans la
création de GE, c'est le général Alain
Gaineron de Marole qui avait recréé le
service action d'USDEC au début des
années 70 et que j'ai rencontré
presque par hasard quand j'étais prof à
l'école
et avec qui j'ai noué un lien d'amitié.
Mar ne m'a jamais rien raconté sur son
activité.
Encore heureux
et c'était un homme très sérieux. En
revanche, en revanche, on a vraiment
parlé
de la culture subversive, des culture du
renseignement, de la sociologie de ce
monde-là, euh de la manière parce que la
grande force de Marole qui était pas
forcément compris même au sein du SDEC
par d'autres, c'est que Marole avait
compris et ça c'est très
un seigneur qu'il fallait fusionner la
culture du faible à la culture du fort
que font les Chinois et les Russes.
Mais bien entendu
là là ce qui se passe alors tu parlais
du fait que bah en 90
bah les Russes ils crevaient un peu la
dalle, ils étaient sous le jouérales
américaines et ainsi de suite. Les
Chinois
les Chinois ils sont quoi ? Ils sont ils
sont un peu fâchés d'avoir été
transformés en toxico il y a 100 ans.
Ils sont un peu fâchés d'avoir été
tabassé par les Japonais d'une façon
innommable.
Oui.
Ils sont ils sont fâchés parce qu' on
les a pris pour des débiles mentaux des
des je vais être vulgaire mais des
cutéreux de de seconde zone.
Et ils ont fermé ils ont fermé leur
bouche. Ils ont courbé ils ont courbé le
dos. Ils ont fait le dos rond. Ils ont
bossé bossé bossé bossé bossé. ce qui a
eu comme peut-être conséquence de faire
émerger un parti très radicalisé.
C'est clair.
Là, ils font quoi les Chinois ? Ils
volent quoi ? Quand on voit la guerre en
Ukraine, quand on voit les Russes, les
Chinois, les Américains, on a
l'impression qu'ils ont tous le feu aux
fesses parce qu'ils ont peur de quelque
chose. Et quand quand les empires ont
peur, les empires deviennent dangereux.
Absolument.
Ils ont peur de quoi les Américains ?
Ils ont peur de quoi les Chinois ? Ils
ont peur de quoi les Russes ? Bon, je
parle pas les Européens parce que les
Européens c'est c'est un petit peu le tu
sais dans le Roi Lyon, tu as tu as des
yennes et nous on est un peu la hienne
un peu débile. Mais ils font ils font
quoi le les Américains ont peur de quoi
? Quelle est la peur de ces empires ?
Alors, je prends je prends une image
vraiment qui permet de de bien cerner ce
que tu viens de dire.
Au début des années 90, quand on
interrogeit les Américains sur la Chine,
c'est qui les Américains ? Alors, ça
pouvait être des représentants du
département d'État, ça pouvait être des
représentants du Pentagone, ça pouvait
être des représentants des services de
renseignement américain, ça pouvait être
des représentants du monde des affaires
et de la finance américaine.
Tu avais cinq avis différents. Les deux
derniers, eux, il était très clair, je
parle du monde des affaires et des
finances, fruit y aller, c'est le nouvel
a de rodo, le parti communiste chinois,
il va s'effondrer comme le parti
communiste russe. Ils sont morts, on y
va. Et on cherche pas trop à aller plus
loin. C'est le nouvel Eldorado en face.
Tu l'as dit, mais les Chinois eux qui
étaient quand même très très faible à la
sortie de la révolution culturelle et
dans la situation
très compliquée du début de la période
tensaing.
Mais toujours avec cet esprit de culture
millénaire. Mais bien entendu, bah ils
ont pondu une stratégie
et la stratégie c'était de leurer le
monde occidental. Ils veulent nous
prendre pour des faibles. Ils veulent
nous considérer comme un Eldorado. Mais
jouons-leur la pièce de l'Eldorado. Et
les Chinois d'ailleurs ont fait beaucoup
plus fort que les Japonais qui eux au à
l'air medji fort dans quel sens ? en
terme de torture ou en terme non non,
les Japonais eux ils ont ils voulaient
pas que les bo les boîtes occidentales
s'installent au Japon.
Ils ont toujours été très vigilant
là-dessus.
Les Japonais ou les Chinois ?
Les Japonais. Mais les Chinois eux ils
ont dit "Venez zone économique spéciale
et on élargit et on passe les John
Venture et cetera mais en corrigeant à
petit les accords commerciaux en serrant
à petit le lac mouillé autour du cou de
ces braves occidentaux qui pensaient
mais faire de très belles affaires,
utiliser une main d'œuvre qui venait
pratiquement rien et cetera et cetera."
Donc j'en reviens à cette image. Quand
tu as cinq caricatures américaines qui
sont pas d'accord et où les deux
dominantes, je parle des années 90 et
surtout le monde des affaires, les
financiers, tu te doutes bien que c'est
compliqué de déchiffrer ce qui se passe
en face. Même si au Patagone, tu as des
gens qui commencent à se dire "On va
avoir des problèmes en mi de Chine, on
va on va risquer des affrontements
peut-être limité, mais il y a un
problème politico-militaire et cetera."
Non,
je vais prendre la défense des Chinois.
Euh quand on voit les Américains
sécuriser le collier de perles depuis
des décennies, tu vois ce que c'est le
collier de perle ? Le collier de perle,
le petit chapelettier,
principale route commerciale chinoise en
30 et sortante.
Ils ont fait aussi l'anaconda autour des
Chinois. Est-ce que Est-ce que tous ces
empires ne créent pas leur propre démon
? Quand je te quand je faisais une
boutade à la Guillaume Meuris d'ailleurs
qui était très bonne école de paix
économique.
Ouais.
Est-ce que tous ces blocs ne créent pas
des Je vais être vulgaire des de
monstres ? À force de les encercler, à
force de se mettre des croches, à force
de tout ça,
ça crée des super monstre. C'est clair.
C'est clair. Alors ce qui est
intéressant quand tu reviens sur
l'histoire de paix économique, tu prends
les 12 résolutions du plan chinois par
rapport à l'Ukraine
qui n'est pas un plan de paix
mais qui n'est pas du tout un plan de
paix mais qui en revanche est
l'expression la plus claire de la
stratégie chinoise pour justement
naviguer en nos troubles et entre les
risques de conflit militaire entre
préserver une certaine forme de
mondialisation des échanges. C'estàd qu'
il continue à tendre la main pour
préserver ce qui leur apporte de
l'argent et qui consolide leur économie.
Ils ont même l'été dernier euh il y a
quand même qui discute avec Macron et le
le chancelier, c'était encore euh est-ce
que c'était la chansonnaire allemande
qui
Oui.
pour dire "Mais venez avec nous,
maintenons les maintenons cette
mondialisation
heureuse pacifique, venez avec nous."
C'està-dire que les Chinois jouent au
GO, on le sait, jouent pas aux échecs,
ils sont, tu disais tout à l'heure, tu
sortais le mot encerclement. Mais ça
c'est un mot hyper important. C'estàd
que quand nous
à l'école de guerre économique, on parle
d'encerclement cognitif et de
contre-encerclement cognitif, on n'est
pas dans l'abstrait, on n'est pas dans
la stratosphère. On essaie d'expliquer
comment celui qui est en cercle endort
l'autre, endort l'autre. le calme, le
caresse, le rassure, lui offre des
petites choses, voir parfois un peu plus
que des petites choses. Chambre garni,
mais bien ça peut aller jusque-là bien
sûr, mais de
chocolat
et ça ça provoque quoi ? Quand je vois
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des groupes du 440
qui n'ont pas de plan B alors que
certains font 30 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires en Chine n'ont pas de plan B
au cas où il y a une rupture avec la
Chine et c'est pour le sadadour on
continue à cachetonner et on s'occupe
pas du reste.
Comment c'est possible ça ? Comment
c'est possible en 2023 d'être encore
dans cette incapacité
de regarder ce qui se passe, de
l'analyser et là on est au niveau des
États-majors de groupe du 440.
Pas de plan B.
Short tongue
peut prendre cette image et encore quoi
que c'est un peu déplacé comme vêtement
pour Non mais on en est là. Donc là, il
y a un vrai problème. Il y a un vrai
problème, c'est que si on en revient à
la France lorsque sort des bouquins
intéressants, j'en prends un. David Tod,
l'empire de velour. Qu'est-ce qu'il
explique David Tod ? Alors, c'est aux
éditions de la découverte. Alors, tout
de suite euh une partie des gens vont
dire édition de la découverte gauchiste,
attention donc il va dénigrer la France.
Gauchiste, c'est un mot interdit ici.
Non, mais en gros, tu vois ce que je
veux dire.
David Tot sort, c'est un universitaire,
il est à Sciencep aujourd'hui, avant il
enseignait dans une ville du
Royaume-Uni. Il nous explique que entre
1815 et la fin du 19e siècle, la France
avait une stratégie stratégie non pas de
conquête territoriale militaire mais une
stratégie de rachat de dettes de pays
pour les rendre dépendants d'elles.
Exemple l'Égypte jusqu'à ce que il y ait
l'arrivée des Britanniques et là avec
leurs troupes militaires. On a même
inventé l'extraterritorialité
du droit avant les Américains. Et
c'était quoi l'extraterritorialité du
droit ? C'est que quand un citoyen
français qui vivait en Égypte, pays
dépendant de la France par achadet,
c'était un juge français qui venait de
juger. C'était pas un juge égyptien.
Donc c'est pas la même que
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
aujourd'hui qui est nettement plus
costaud en terme
invasive.
Voilà exactement. Donc et bien qui a lu
le livre de David Tod ? Non pas pour
dire "Ah le méchant capitalisme et non
pour essayer de comprendre comment dans
notre pays il y a eu des évolutions
stratégiques. Il y a eu des périodes où
il y avait des gens qui vraiment avaient
des plans en tête pour avancer. Alors je
vais pas les juger sur le fond, je vais
pas dire c'est bien, c'est mal mais il y
avait de la stratégie.
Là, souvent à l'école de guerre
économique, on fait de l'archéologie,
c'est on ramasse des petits morceaux du
vase, non pas de soisson, mais qui tombe
par terre pour les recoller.
Pour les recoller, c'est-à-dire qu'on
essaie de comprendre
comment reconstituer le cheminement de
notre propre histoire pour essayer de
voir où sont les ruptures, où est-ce
qu'il y a eu des
discontinuités.
les étapes qu'on a raté. Tu parlais de
l'armée et de la guerre économique. Bah
oui, Première Guerre mondiale.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi des étapes qu'on a
raté ?
Ah bah, je te donne un exemple. On a un
militaire qui s'appelle Liutenant
Colonel Lae qui a écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle le nerf de la guerre, première
guerre mondiale qui revient sur les
archives du service historique des
armées et qui explique que durant la
première guerre mondiale, là c'est très
français, il y avait une étude avant le
déclenchement de la guerre sur attention
les pays neutres vont jouer un rôle non
négligeable s'il y a une guerre
militaire. Mais
tu as fait une conférence avec lui ?
Non. Exactement.
Qui était qui était qui était filmé avec
une caméra de surveillance et et
enregistré avec un baby phone. Non,
voilà, c'est à peu près ça. À la Viette
si tu veux. Et donc
à la quoi c'est pas de l'époque. OK.
Oui. Ouais. Enfin, j'exagère mais c'est
quand même ça. Et
d'ailleurs, j'en profite pour dire
bonjour à Toan et à Vintan.
Le message est passé. Et donc qu'est-ce
qui nous explique ? c'est que au début
de la guerre là, le vieux rapport que
personne ne voulait lire et prendre en
compte, on le ressort et on découvre que
la guerre 141, ça va être aussi une
guerre économique redoutable. George
Jean Itsutu a écrit un très bon bouquin
là-dessus, mais des historiens
militaires aussi du service historique
des armées justement et la qui revient
avec un bouquin qui nous explique qu'on
invente un système. On invente un
système pour regarder ce qui se passe
dans les pays neutres. Ensuite pour
installer des réseaux d'agent, ensuite
pour commencer à saboter, à parasiter.
Là on voit apparaître, il parle d'un
agent,
tu parlais tout à l'heure de truant.
C'est pas un truant mais c'est un type
qui est quand même borderline. Ce
type-là, il va jouer un rôle très
intéressant. Il a tellement envie de se
battre ce type là qui va même affrêter
un bateau.
Bien entendu, l'armée française va pas
l'armer. C'est les britanniques qui vont
armer son bateau. Il va aller couler des
cargos qui transportent des produits
nécessaires à l'Allemagne pour continuer
la guerre.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Est-ce qu'on
peut faire le même parap le même
parallèle avec Nordstream ? Est-ce que
Nordstream qui pète parce que là là on
entend que le gouvernement ukrain dit ça
ça a rien à voir avec nous. le
gouvernement américain qui dit ça n'a
rien à voir avec nous, c'est un groupe
de proiniens.
Est-ce que est-ce que
si monsieur Erche dit dit bah c'est les
Américains avec les Norvégiens pour
vendre le gaz, vous comprenez ? Puis
avec d'autres gars, est-ce que ça peut
être des renégs qui ont décidé de on va
taper Nordstream ? Parce qu'il faut
quand même décider un peu les Allemands
à faut les décider à arrêter. Non mais
je te réponds à ça mais en prenant
l'exemple en
c'est la fine équipe du Rainbow Warrior
mais j'entends bien mais je garde
l'exemple pour aller sur sur la question
que tu poses. Le type en question il
était tellement efficace qu'à un moment
donné il est rentré dans des conflits
d'individus. On l'a rapatrié en France
et on a failli l'envoyer au front en
première ligne comme simple bidas.
D'accord. Là heureusement il a été
protégé. On l'a mis dans un placard et
on l'a ressorti et c'est devenu un type
qui rendait compte à Clémenceau,
président du Conseil sur ce qu'il
faisait parce qu'il était retourné dans
ces fameux pays nôtres du nord de
l'Europe pour continuer à saboter
l'approvisionnement de l'Allemagne.
finança c'était les britanniques, les
français céit
non là c'était du financement français
et tu avais un vrai système au ministère
de la guerre ministère de la guerre qui
gérait ça et qui l'avait
professionnalisé à tel point que et ça
c'est une très belle découverte de la ce
type en question il va filer de l'argent
aux embryons du mouvement spartaquiste
allemand pour déstabiliser
sur zone des troupes notamment les
fameux marins.
C'est du financement français. On s'est
baissait sur l'art allemand qui amène le
brave lénine de Suisse
en Russie pour accélérer le processus
révolutionnaire. Mais les Français ont
fait une chose quasiment identique sous
un autre genre. Donc on a un système
comme ça. À la fin de la Première Guerre
mondiale, l'armée dit "Mais voilà,
continuons ce système en temps de paix."
Terminé. Et là, je reviens à ta
question. l'opération sur sur le euh le
Northstream et le pipe.
Ah, je suis désolé, c'est pas la 4e
équipe du Rainbow Warrior, quoi. C'est
pas des mecs sur un sur un voilier qui
vont plonger à poser une petite charge.
Oh, c'était 40 m et on a retrouvé des
traces d'explosif sur le yach
appartenant à un Ukrainien. C'est sûr.
Ouais, c'est sûr. Non, faut être sérieux
quoi.
C'est une action redoutable avec un
résultat redoutable. Nous d'ailleurs, on
en subit indirectement certaines
conséquences. Les Allemands, mais pas
que les Allemands. Et là, on voit
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'aspect
politico-militaire de la guerre
économique parce que c'est une véritable
opération.
Est-ce que tu as vu le la le discours du
directeur de chez Stratford de 2015 ?
Non, j'ai pas vu.
Ah, je te le conseille. C'est petit
caviard, ça dure 11 minutes et des
passages et et des brouettes.
Stratford directeur. Vous avez vous avez
trouvé ça c'est euh organisé par un sing
tank américain.
OK.
C'est c'est à voir. 2015. Et revenons à
Norstream.
On en est où là ? Est-ce que il y a une
enquête ? Il y a pas d'enquête ? Est-ce
que
Est-ce que Est-ce que ça va avancer plus
que ça ?
On a des précédents quand même. Les
précédents,
c'est
tout sera fait pour qu'il y ait zéro
résultat. Mais non, c'est pas possible
ça.
Et ben, on va voir. On prend le paris.
Tu crois peut-être qu'on va voir arriver
subitement une information comme quoi
c'est les services de renseignement
américain qui ont pété leur stream ?
Mais c'est peut-être pas eux.
D'accord. Disons une force qui a la même
capacité de frappe, mais c'est pas
possible, c'est pas acceptable, c'est
pas gérable. Donc on ne saura pas. Mais
ça va dans les deux sens. Euh un livre
très intéressant euh de Philippe Maçon,
l'homme et la guerre explique que
durant la guerre froide, quand les
Français ont fourni aux Américains les
documents de l'affaire Farwell,
c'est-à-dire des milliers de documents
l'affaire Farwell, l'affaire Vladimir
Vetrof, grâce à nous services français,
je te laisse expliquer un peu
un je sais plus quel grade il avait un
officier supérieur du KGB bébé qui
travaillait dans la direction qui
s'occupait pour faire simple du pillage
technique et technologique du côté monde
occidental notamment trahi et balance
pourquoi
ça c'est toute une histoire je vais je
je préfère rester sur cette ligne de
crête il trahit et il fournit à la
direction d'assurance du territoire dans
le contreespionnage policier français
une masse énorme d'informations et
finalement l'information est transmise
aux Américains. Mais vas-y, donne un
petit détail quand même. Pourquoi
Farwell ? Pourquoi tout ça ? Parce que
il file au français et à Mitéran.
Oui.
Le fait que les Russes ont les codes
pour annuler les frappes nucléaires
américaines. Et quand Mteran, on lui
pose la question, un américain lui dit
"Comment allez-vous, monsieur Mitteran
?" Et lui dit "Farel".
Tout à fait.
Dans le bouquin de maçon, je termine
parce que tu vas comprendre, il y a un
il y a un américain
qui est dans le système américain qui
voit ça et qui dit "D'accord,
il nous pille comme ça et ben on va leur
piéger des choses et il piègent les
choses et ça réussit parce que ça
provoque sur le territoire de l'Union
soviétique un certain nombre de
problèmes.
Ce type là, il passe sa vie, il se
retrouve en retraite
et il va voir une fin
qui est que je pense que les Russes se
sont souvenus de lui et l'ont dégagé.
C'est une nonhistoire.
Mais bien sûr, ils l'ont flingué. C'est
une nonhistoire. C'est-à-dire que ça
marche dans les deux sens dans ces
logiques de coût tordu et d'opération
spécifique avec des enjeux quand même
lourds parce que les deux exemples,
c'est des enjeux lourds. Le gaz d'un
côté et de l'autre, comment tu pièges
celui qui est en train de te piller pour
lui fausser l'utilisation d'un certain
nombre de technologies, c'est des enjeux
lourds. On est dans la partie
sombre et invisible de l'histoire.
Est-ce que tu as vu passer le fait que
un officier du renseignement allemand
s'est fait retourner par les Russes pour
90000 € ? Ça t'a fait penser à quoi
quand tu as vu se passer ça ? C'est très
récent et d'ailleurs, il aurait fourni
aux russes des secrets français de la
DGSE.
Alors bon là, on est dans dans un
univers particulier. N'oublie pas que
moi je suis dans dans les sources
ouvertes et je suis comme toi, je
réceptionne ce genre de choses. Ce qui
est sûr, c'est qu'actuellement les
Russes sont très actifs en France.
Le problème des Français, c'est qu'ils
ont identifié un certain nombre d'agents
russes. Il fut un temps où le
contre-espionnage français menait des
opérations de contre-espionnage
dioffensif.
Ça se fait toujours.
Oui, mais pas
avec le même talent et la même liberté
d'action.
Attends, ils ont quand même chopé les
gars.
Oui. Non non, mais quand ils peuvent les
choper et aller jusqu'au bout, expulsion
ou autre, OK, mais là, je parle pas de
les choper. Là, je parle de tenter de
les retourner. Je parle de tenter de
leur faire perdre la face. Il y a une
scène qui est une très belle scène de la
DST. où il piège un agent du bloc de
l'Est dans un restaurant et tous les
gens du restaurant sont des gens de la
DST, ceux qui servent, ceux qui sont au
comptoir et cetera. Et le type, je te
laisse imaginer la tête qu'il a, mais le
but c'était de le casser
psychologiquement, c'était à la limite
même pas de l'expulser, retourner des
agents. Mais aujourd'hui,
retourner des agents, faut prendre des
risques. Et c'est vrai DGSE comme la
DST, la notion de prise de risque. Prise
de risque,
je suis désolé,
c'est quelque chose de compliqué.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons des situations
dans l'Organisation française. Il y a un
bruit de fond qui circule dans les
coulisses de des médias. 1000 personnes
ont quitté la DGSE sur 7000.
Donc c'est un bruit de couloir ça.
Je suis pas sûr que ça soit un bruit de
couloir.
Un bruit de couloir, c'est un truc qui
traîne pas sourcé. Je non non parce que
ce bruit là moi je l'ai pas entendu
forcément dans un couloir.
Pourquoi il y a ce problème ? Imagine
c'est un problème qui n'est pas sourcé
donc apprendre
mettons que ça soit un mais et si
c'était vrai d'accord quelle est
l'entreprise qui peut se permettre de
perdre 17e de ces effectifs ?
Aucune.
Quand tu as besoin de réduire les coûts,
c'est pas ch Oui
oui oui. Non mais là là attention ceux
qui partent, c'est pas ceux qu'on
dégage, c'est ceux qui décident de
partir.
Mais ils partent pour se reconvertir
dans le privé, dans le civil ou ils se
font retourner pour d'autres puissances
?
Non, pas du tout. C'est des gens qui euh
qui sont déçus, qui sont frustrés. Euh
la
DRM, il y en a combien qui sont partis ?
Je sais pas. Mais mais ce qui est clair,
c'est que tu as un problème. Si ce
problème est si l'information est
réelle, c'est un véritable problème.
C'est un problème. Comment fonctionne le
système ? Tu me parlais en tout début
d'émission, la guerre économique, la
guerre de l'information, la guerre
cognitive. On a parlé de guerre
économique, on a parlé de guerre
cognitive.
Parlons de la guerre de l'information.
La guerre de l'information, c'est une
guerre
offensive.
Question.
On est offensif coup.
Et ben voilà. Et ben tu as répondu.
Comment on passe à l'offensive ? Qui
veut mener une guerre ?
Tu as vu les couteaux affutés qu'on a
dans le tiroir ? Non mais sans déconner.
Non mais
c'est Non mais on a un problème. Le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est qu'en
trouvant tous les prétextes possibles et
imaginable, les faux prétextes, c'est
qu'on ne veut pas mener de guerre
offensive. Encore une fois, je rouvre un
tiroir d'une ancienne vie juillet et au
responsable à l'intelligence économique
Alain juillet. à l'in juillet.
Je revendique le fait de lui avoir
suggéré de créer un groupe de travail,
on va pas appeler ça garde de
l'information sur le risque
informationnel. Il le crée. Je suis
habilité pour y participer. Je suis le
seul privé à participer alors qu'il n'y
a que des fonctionnaires. Je suis la
cheville ouvrière du sous-groupe mode
opératoire et je m'arrêterai là parce
que le reste est classifié. Mais le
résultat de ce travail, le résultat de
ce travail, c'est de dire
la guerre de l'information,
elle n'est qu'offensive. La guerre de
l'information défensive, ça ne veut
strictement rien dire. Ça ne rapporte
quasiment rien. C'est un peu l'image de
la gestion de crise en entreprise, si tu
veux.
Est-ce que Est-ce que à force de trop
être offensif, ça peut être
contreproductif ? Bien sûr, mais bien
entendu, mener de l'offensive, c'est pas
être un gros bourrin qui fonce pour
exploser la tête de tout le monde avec
des idées bien arrêtées et une certaine
agressivité naturelle. Non,
il les faire passer pour des débiles.
C'est ça
exactement. On peut être dans la
finesse,
on peut choisir,
on peut avoir des résultats pertinents
mais à une seule condition. Encore
faut-il appuyer sur le bouton.
D'accord.
Est-ce que ça c'est pas des des villes
mesures qui ne vont que créer encore
plus de monstres autour de nous ? Est-ce
qu'il faut pas avoir un corps
diplomatique qui mette les choses à plat
calmement ? Là, on a l'impression que le
corps diplomatique, c'est simplement
pour gagner du temps, faire passer la
pilule et et et polir genre gentiment un
peu, tu vois. La puberchar
ou
d'accord. Donc est-ce qu'il faut pas un
vrai corps diplomatique où on se pose et
on parle franchement ? Franchement ça
veut dire
on arrête de se mettre des couteaux dans
le dos parce qu'il y a un réchauffement
climatique dramatique qui va tous nous
toucher et si on se la joue trop perso,
bah ça risque d'être compliqué. Est-ce
qu' il faut pas un moment un autre
arrêter de se faire la guerre ? On dit
tout le temps à l'air du nucléaire le
seul ennemi c'est la guerre. H bien sûr.
Est-ce est-ce qu'il faut pas arrêter les
anciennes méthodes
et prendre un nouveau chemin ? Et est-ce
que la France avec ce qui lui reste de
crédibilité
Oui.
devrait pas
prendre le le la tête ou le lead de de
ça.
Moi, je crois que c'est une excellente
idée.
Est-ce que c'est pas trop un peu trop
bison nours ?
Non, je crois pas. Bien entendu, il faut
quand même avoir la capacité de de ne
pas se faire balader ou pas trop se
faire mordre. Mais la stratégie qui
reste à l'Europe même au-delà même de la
France, c'est d'être une force de
proposition de paix. Mais pas comme la
Société des nations et où on se retrouve
à Munique avec les pseudos résultats de
la négociation, on a préservé la paix.
Tu te souviens de l'histoire et tout le
monde en partie s'en souvient là. Oui,
il est clair que si il doit y avoir une
stratégie France et une stratégie
Europe, c'est pour arriver à un accord
d'arrêt des combats en Ukraine. Ça c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument
fondamental même à l'échelle
internationale haute que l'Ukraine
mais bien entendu mais même sur d'autres
fronts
avec tout le respect qu'on peut avoir
pour les milliers de morts l'Ukraine le
conflit ukrainien ça n'est que l'écume
des choses. On est parfaitement
d'accord. Mais pour aller
derrière derrière il y a le deuxième
effet qui se coule la Chine
bien sûr
Taiïwan.
Mais pour aller dans cette direction là
si on n pas les moyens tu parlais d'une
mutation du Kedoré qui est en cours
d'ailleurs parce que on voit apparaître
des jeunes diplomates qui ont envie de
faire ce que tu dis, qui ont envie
d'être utiles, qui ont envie de de
rentrer dans un processus. Allez, je
vais prendre un terme marxiste
dialectique au bon sens du terme.
C'estàd que vraiment il y ait des
enchaînements de d'actions qui
aboutissent à du concret. Mais c'est
évident que un c'est pas le problème du
somnambulisme, c'est le problème de la
perte de mémoire.
Non, mais tu parles du somnambulisme en
faisant référence au dormur au dormeur
du quai.
Non non, je parle de cette expression
qui revient de plus en plus comme quoi
nous sommes des somnambules qui allons
droit vers la guerre. Moi je
oui, c'est un constat mais ce que je ce
que je veux simplement dire c'est qu'il
faut surtout pas être amnésique.
Et pas être amnésique, c'est bien
comprendre les deux dernières guerres
mondiales, comment elles se sont
déclenchées, pourquoi, qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pour arriver à ce que tu
suggères. C'est-à-dire qu'on fasse pas
un bis répétita avec des gens qui se
laissent sans même s'en rendre compte et
là je parle des peuples de nouveau
engagé dans une logique d'engrenage qui
va les amener au grand n'importe quoi
d'une logique militaire parce que la
finalité de la logique militaire on la
connaît. On la connaît.
Qu'est-ce que ça rapporte ? Attends,
non, parce que les militaires,
c'est pas eux les responsables.
Je ne je n'incrimine pas les militaires.
Je
la guerre, c'est
Je suis d'accord avec ça. Je dis ne
confondons pas ne confondons pas la
définition des objectifs. Bien sûr qu'il
faut une armée, bien sûr qu'il faut
qu'elle s'entraîne. Bien sûr qu'il faut
qu'elle soit équipée. Bien sûr que
qu'elle doit être capable éventuellement
de nous défendre si le besoin s'en fait
sentir, mais à une seule condition,
c'est que
cette réalitéélournable
ne doit pas masquer les autres. Et les
autres, c'est quoi ? Dans le monde dans
lequel on entre progressivement, la
priorité absolue, c'est d'éviter la
confrontation thermonucléaire. Et je dis
pas ça en étant un idiot utile du bloc
post-soviétique qui a joué sur ces
questions-là à certains moments. Je dis
ça tout simplement parce que les peuples
européens là je parle des peuples
européens
ne veulent pas aller dans cette
direction.
Cet engrenage là ils n'en veulent pas.
C'est quoi tes sources ?
les sources. On n toujours pas fait de
sondage pour demander au français qui
est prêt à revêtir l'uniforme pour aller
combattre sur le terrain militaire. Ou
mais ça c'est pas une c'est pas un
argument ça.
Oui mais c'est quand même une réalité.
Bien qu'il y a aucun sondage qui voulait
pas se castagner hein.
Oui oui. Non mais tu vois ce que je veux
dire. On fait des sondages dans tous les
sens mais là il y en a pas.
Et pourquoi il y en a pas ? Et tout
simplement parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'il y a un écart monumental entre les
discours sur la guadre haute intensité
et ce fait de s'y préparer et l'attitude
des peuples par rapport à ça. Pourquoi
je dis il faut pas être amnésique ?
Il fallait il fallait rester il fallait
rester passif quand il y a une invasion
à 3 ans de Paris. Il fallait faire quoi
?
Non, il fallait un et ça a été fait, je
pense.
Prévenir,
ça aurait été intéressant de prévenir,
mais pour prévenir, on retombe sur les
sur les problèmes habituels. Quelles
sont les stratégies des uns et des
autres ? Quelles sont les pierres qui
bougent sur le goban comme on dit au jeu
de go ? Qui fait quoi et où est-ce qu'on
est nous ? Si nous on est simplement un
pays supplétif qui suit une stratégie
qui nous dépasse et qu'on ne cherche pas
à voir ou à contrer, faut pas venir
pleurer après. On suit et on entre dans
l'engrenage. Si on a ce courage, mais on
l'a eu parfois, je vais pas revenir sur
l'exemple cité qui nous a coûté cher,
mais on a assumé le prix de pas aller
dans la guerre en Irak comme ça a été
décidé à un certain moment.
Et je pense qu'on n pas eu tort de ne
pas aller dans la guerre en Irak.
Les Américains l'ont fait payer, hein,
ils ont débon en pay mais il faut
accepter de payer certains prix de
certaines décisions.
Est-ce que là Est-ce que là la France
elle est tellement au short
économiquement parlant qu'elle peut plus
payer ?
Elle peut plus payer sa souveraineté.
Elle peut plus payer. Si elle sort du
rang, si elle sort de la grande vague,
soit vous êtes avec nous, soit vous êtes
contre nous, on est tellement en short
que
c'est un peu l'explication qui est dit
ici et là, c'est-à-dire
c'est où ici et là ?
Bah dans certains ministères, dans
certains centres de décision.
C'est quoi tes sources ? les sources et
quand on discute avec des fonctionnaires
qui sont aux manettes et qui disent
"Vous êtes bien gentil avec vos
propositions X ou Y mais voilà la
situation
et la situation c'est que effectivement
effectivement nous sommes un pays
fragile mais
je repasse la bobine à l'envers
et je le fais par provocation.
On est un pays de
et au tout début. C'était quoi ?
C'était quoi ? Ils étaient pas fragiles.
Alors nous, on le situe où le curseur de
la fragilité ? Parce que si on commence
à faire un peu d'histoire contemporaine,
on va voir que des petites forces
fragiles, alors certes qui ont été
aidées par la suite par des grosses
forces.
Gapéoimine au début, c'est les
États-Unis, après ça a été la Chine
communiste puis l'Union soviétique et
cetera. Mais
n'empêche que ces petites forces se sont
battues et ont remporté d'abord des
petites victoires puis ensuite des
grandes victoires.
C'est la stratégie qui se passe en
Ukraine avec Zensinski.
Je pense qu'il s'inscrit un peu dans un
schéma de ce type, sachant que
il a en face de lui la Russie.
Donc il a en face de lui un pays qui a
la mémoire de cette culture.
Alors tu parles de quelle mémoire ? De
la bravoure, de se sacrifier, de c'est
cette culture un peu triste et cynique
face à la mort
d'une part. Mais aussi la culture
subversive.
Elle a pas été forcément enterrée avec
la disparition du mur de Berlin. Il y a
certes, elle a muté.
C'est quoi comme métier Poutine avant ?
Bah, il était officier du KGB, je crois,
si j'ai bonne mémoire. Donc il y a tout
cette
rqueur
rancœur cet acquis euh je pense quand
même et c'est pas pour excuser le fait
qu'ils envahissent un pays et qu'ils
l'attaquent militairement mais on sait
très bien que sousine euh
les Américains
étaient là à côté d'Elsine et que on
peut imaginer qu'en Russie
sans parler de renaissance du communisme
été détesté hein. Il il est toujours
il y avait un problème quoi. Il y avait
un problème. Il y avait un problème. Tu
te fais pas euh
ligoter littéralement comme ça avec ce
pays son histoire compliquée, difficile
mais
on paye on paye l'attitude de la Russie
dû à l'effondrement de 90 et le fait que
les États-Unis
les les leur ont marché sur leur ont
marché dessus quoi. Les ont laissé
sans dignité. sans rien. C'est la
génération qui est au pouvoir
maintenant. La plupart c'est la
génération de 90.
On est bien d'accord.
Et eux et eux se rappellent très très
bien des misères.
Quand on on connaît bien la règle qu'il
faut toujours sauver la face quelque
part d'un pays que tu
que tu mets à genou, faut quand même lui
laisser une porte de sortie. Je pense
que sur ce qui s'est passé en Russie en
la période, il y avait pas vraiment de
porte de sortie. C'était un régime qui
était
en train de s'effondrer
et il n'est pas étonnant de voir le
rebond par la suite. C'était logique.
Ils ont fait un rebond à la chinoise.
Alors, ils l'ont fait partiellement. Ils
l'ont fait sur le complexe militaire
industriel. Ils l'ont fait sur euh
éviter l'apparition d'un capitalisme
russe
qui échappait au contrôle potentiel d'un
pouvoir politique
recherchant une nouvelle souveraineté.
Ça c'est en l'occurrence Poutine parce
que c'est un peu trop facile de dire
Poutine c'est un copain de ceux qui se
mettent de l'argent plein les poches.
Regardez. Oui, il a un yachot. on l'a
pas intercepté quand il était près de
Monaco et cetera. OK, mais attendez,
alors là, on peut là on peut faire les
comparaisons à tous les étages dans tous
les systèmes et tous les empires. Ça
c'est vraiment des arguments qui ont pas
beaucoup de poids. La vraie réalité
c'est qu'on n'assume pas effectivement
la manière dont les États-Unis
se comportent en terme d'empire.
On n'arrive pas à digérer cette cette
réalité là et on narrive surtout pas à
en parler.
Ça c'est un énorme problème.
Pourquoi on peut pas en parler ?
Parce que on s'est tellement habitué à
la dépendance,
faut pas oublier qu'on est allé chercher
les États-Unis après 45 pour qu'il
maintiennent des bases américaines en
Europe par peur
surtout
en France d'une réaction du Parti
communiste français. qui était le
premier parti de France et
éventuellement d'une dégradation de la
situation en Europe à cause des
positions prises en Europe de l'Est.
Donc la sécurité est devenue la sécurité
américaine
et quand même ils font le gendarme du
monde depuis un certain nombre d'années
et on s'est donc habitué à ça
pour leur propre pour leurs propres
intérêts.
Bah c'est c'est pas gratuit tout ça, on
le sait. Mais aujourd'hui, on aurait pu
quand même depuis la fin de la guerre
froide essayer de prendre une certaine
distance, essayer de redevenir un tout
petit peu lucide sur ce qu'on cette
expression qui qui est apparue de
manière éphémère, recherche d'autonomie
stratégique au niveau de l'Europe. Bon,
elle en est où l'autonomie stratégique
de l'Europe ? Il y en a pas, on le sait.
Donc, mais
ce à quoi je crois, moi je cherche à
être optimiste sur ce terrain là. Je ne
crois pas qu'on pourra éternellement
rouler les peuples dans la farine.
Et je pense qu'effectivement
dans un pays tel que la France qui
apparaît comme affaibli avec des gens
qui sont pas trop sur le terrain, on va
s'y mettre pour retrousser les manches
et affronter tout ça.
Il y en a pas qui se s'automissionnent.
Il faudrait qu'il y en ait plus
justement, mais ça commence à
apparaître. Je dirais le vent euh qui
commence à souffler légèrement, la brise
qui commence à souffler légèrement,
c'est des gens qui s'automissionnent,
c'est des gens qui commencent à créer
des réponses, qui commencent à créer des
réponses déjà dans la
réindustrialisation, qui commence à
créer des réponses déjà au niveau
syndical
dans les médias.
Alors dans les médias,
c'est pas encore le cas. C'estàd que là
il y a du boulot comme on dit. Mais déjà
sur le plan économique, ça c'est
important. On parlait de l'agriculture,
on voit des gens qui changent de
posture, on voit des gens qui se mettent
à réfléchir. On voit même des gens qui
se mettent à se parler alors qu'il ne se
parlent pas. Là, il y a quelque chose.
Il y a quelque chose qui est très
important. Et je ne peux que reciter
parce que ça m'a fait vraiment du bien
moi de vivre ça, cette fameuse réunion à
l'université de Nanterre,
600 étudiants en face.
Et quand on leur dit
vous êtes pas des sous-étudiants d'une
université populaire,
vous êtes la force qui doit constituer
une nouvelle France
pour créer quelque chose, pour aller de
l'avant.
Et ça quand je vois à ma grande
surprise, non pas un petit
applaudissement privé,
discret, mais une ovation et là c'est
pas Arbulo, on s'en fout d'Arbullo,
c'est une ovation à l'idée qui est
émise. Là, je me dis
à mon époque Maïste, on parlait de
mouvement de la jeunesse. D'accord ? Là,
je dis alors c'est pas un mouvement de
la jeunesse maïs, mais il y a un
mouvement de la jeunesse potentielle qui
veut exister. qui veut pas se faire
détruire, qui veut pas rentrer dans un
engrenage, qui veut vivre sa liberté
existentielle.
Mais vieux vieux, ils sont une poignée,
faut te réveiller là.
Oui, oui, oui. Mais attention, alors
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas des
lunettes roses de j'ai envie de de voir
non. Attention,
je le char exprès
à la poignée
qui a cette consistance
quand il s'agit de sauver sa peau, son
âme, son envie de vivre, sa soif de vie.
les minorités agissantes qui vont se
mobiliser pour sauver leur soif de vie
et pas pleurer sur le taux de CO2
simplement ou le passage du véhicule
taux de CO2 quand même.
Mais je dis j'ai dit pas seulement
sauver sa soif de vie, son envie de
vivre.
Là, il y a quelque chose. Là, il y a
quelque chose. Et tu me posais la
question tout à l'heure, mais le GE, il
y en a combien qui porte ça ?
Quel profil ? Combien ça coûte ? Et
ainsi de suite.
On sort, on est une toute petite
structure, on est à 350 370 étudiants
par an. Bon,
c'est combien l'année pour par tête de
pipe ?
C'est entre
8000 et 12000 € parce que plus tôt on
s'inscrit, moins on paye. Baiss tu as tu
as baissé tes tarifs,
pardon ? Tu as baissé tes tarifs,
on n'est pas cher, on les a pas, on les
augmente pas. D'ailleurs, on nous dit
"Mais attendez euh ça fait 20 ans que
vous êtes premier à certains
classement." Alors oui, le classement
est bidon, il n'est pas si bidon que ça.
Et on augmente pas nos tarifs.
Bah non, on les augmente pas. Et on fait
mieux même. Alors, je vais pas jouer le
commercial de je vais pas citer de
marque, mais sur les formations
exécutives, donc pour les pros, on
rajoute une centaine d'heures à la
formation. On approfondit des choses.
Pourquoi ? Parce que cette idée initiale
de l'école de guerre économique,
c'est de garder un cap. Et le cap, c'est
d'être utile à un pays autant que faire
ce peut. Le GE jamais aucune structure
ne l'a aidé en 26 ans. Alors, on va dire
super, vous êtes indépendant. C'est un
énorme point faible pour certains.
Vous avez jamais été aidé. Mais vous
êtes qui alors ? Et ben, on est ce que
la ce que le Kings College dit. On a
inventé un truc avant les British quoi.
Coucor
pour une fois.
Euh Bruno Lomè, il est bien conseillé.
On voit beaucoup de ministres. Pourquoi
tu fermes les yeux comme ça ?
Elle me fait pas marrer.
Donc on voit on voit
nos politiques
faire de la gestion de panique,
de la gestion de panique avec le Covid,
de la gestion de panique avec la guerre
en Ukraine, de la gestion de panique à
chaque fois. Est-ce que quand on en
arrive à ne faire que de la gestion de
panique, c'est qu'on est en short et en
tongue ?
En tout cas euh je dirais qu'on est euh
dans la Jet Society mentale.
C'est quoi la Jet Society mentale Ouais.
C'est-à-dire qu'on n pas forcément, on
peut porter un col roulé de temps en
temps, mais on n'est pas forcément en
short et on tombe, quoi. C'est-à-dire,
on n pas envie de rentrer dans tout ce
qu'on vient d'évoquer depuis le début
parce que c'est pas marrant, parce que
ça veut dire qu'il va falloir trimer,
parce que ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
prendre des risques.
Mais mais je vais prendre la défense de
Bruno Lemire, annoncer la couleur tout
de suite avec les informations que nous
on peut avoir. Et les français ils font
spendre où il y a la révolte révolution,
ils vont demander des comptes directs.
Donc moi, moi je vais dire je remercie
Bruno Lemer et je remercie Macron. Il
nous offre des vacances avec de la
dette. Ils font de la gestion de panique
avec de la bobologie et avec du ngge du
nudge sur la population. Et c'est Merci
les gars. Euh
je sais pas si ça mais
il y a un petit détail quand même dans
dans tout ça. C'est pas pour rien que je
parle de Jet Society.
C'est
tu as pas oublié que la révolution
française elle commence une révolte
contre les privilèges
et ceux qui ont faim.
un moment donné, il lève les yeux et il
regarde quoi ? Ceux qui ont des
privilèges.
Et là, en ce moment,
le véritable moteur de l'histoire qui
peut se mettre à commencer à faire un
peu de bruit,
c'est l'estomac.
C'est l'estomac qui fait lever les yeux
vers ceux qui ont des privilèges. Et la
faille, elle est là.
Et c'est la raison pour laquelle je dis
qu'il est urgent
que le pouvoir politique
assume enfin ses responsabilités,
c'est-à-dire un
face de la stratégie
commence un peu à
reprendre une minimum un minimum pardon
de distance et oublier cette dépendance
quasi automatique qu'on a vis-à-vis
notamment des États-Unis.
Prendre des risques, prendre des
risques,
dire on va mettre à genou l'économie
russe au début de la guerre en Ukraine,
c'est pas prendre un risque. C'est
simplement risquer de se tromper.
Mais c'est surtout c'est surtout exciter
les autres en face les et franchement
quand on a vu les décis désolé quand on
a vu les déclaration de Bruno le mer
on s'est dit mais allô tu sais que tu es
au courant qu'ils sont bien entraînés
pour sortir de Swift qu'ils ont mis de
leur de côté des munitions de côté
qu'ils sont préparés à sortir d'internet
et là tu entends Bruno le maire sortir
ça mais il y a pas quelqu'un qui lui qui
lui retire le micro il se fait recadrer
par Medved Vedev dans la foulée,
c'est c'est quand même dramatique.
Mais c'est parce que on parlait de
guerre cognitive, guerre économique,
guerre de l'information.
Il y a pas ce logiciel là.
Je ne suis pas sûr que Bruno Lemer sache
qui il a en face au niveau de
l'épaisseur historique de l'Union
soviétique et de la Russie.
Tu m'as fait peur. J'ai cru que tu
allais dire que Bruno Lemer, tu es pas
sûr s'il a un logiciel, tu vois.
Non, je je pense pas qu'il ait cette
culture, mais je pense pas qu'Emmanuel
Macron n'est cette culture. Le drame, il
est là. C'est-à-dire que quand tu formes
des élites pendant des dizaines d'années
en disant "Ce qui compte c'est le marché
mondial, on va créer un système unifié,
une mondialisation qui banalise tout ça,
on nura plus de guerre, tout va bien se
passer."
Bah tu faut pas venir une fois de plus
après se dire "Mais pourquoi n'avait-il
pas quand même un minimum de prudence ?
Il faut il faut des paranos dans la
guerre économique ?"
Non, je dirais pas des paranox parce que
les paranox ça amène toujours des
catastrophes.
Des vigilants. Alors
des gens vigilants, des gens agiles, des
gens réactifs, des gens qui qui soient
pas des psychigides, qui soient pas dans
les stratégies en silo. Moi, ce qui me
désespère aujourd'hui, c'est de voir des
responsables qui s'abritent derrière des
textes pour dire "Ah, c'est pas dans les
textes, je ne fais pas".
Mais si ces si ces gens-là en septembre
il respecte la même logique mais il
serait pas dans la résistance hein, il
serait ailleurs. Et aujourd'hui, il faut
être dans la résistance une nouvelle
forme de résistance.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes avant ça ? Est-ce que tu as trois
bouquins à nous conseiller à
conseiller conseiller à la à la
communauté ? Est-ce que attends avant
ça, est-ce que tu veux qu'on parle d'un
autre truc ?
Non non, ça va. Je crois que on a épuisé
plein de trucs déjà. Je crois qu'ils
doivent être largement
Non non t'inquiète, ils ont ils ont un
cerveau bien résilient et ça fait bien
longtemps qu'il s'affutent.
Bon tant mieux.
Trois bouquins.
Alors un bouquin d'un auteur que j'aime
beaucoup, je l'ai cité, Philippe Masson
parce qu'il est tombé dans les
oubliettes. C'est un historien militaire
et qui a vraiment l'homme et la guerre.
Je crois que c'est hélas un livre
d'actualité et il faut aller boire à
cette source. Ensuite, il y en a un qui
s'appelle Jean Leu qui est lui aussi un
historien et qui a écrit Combattre en
dictature. Et pourquoi ce livre ? Parce
que c'est au moment du débarquement
juin 44, c'est la Vermarthe
comment elle réagit. et on parlait de
résilience.
L'image que je retiens de ce livre,
c'est quand le leu démontre que ceux qui
venaient du front de l'Est et qui
arrivaient en Normandie,
ils en arrivaient presque à dire qu'il
venait d'un front facile parce que il y
a cette image d'une compagnie allemande
qui voit arriver 20 bombardiers
qui se disent c'est pas pour nous.
C'est pour derrière et qui se prend les
20 bombardiers et qu'après il y a une
deuxè vague et c'est 40 bombardiers et
après il y a une troisème vague et c'est
100 bombardiers. C'est-à-dire que là le
le il nous remet en perspective la
réalité de la guerre sous différents
angles et comment les Allemands arrivent
malgré le fait de se faire déchiqueter
la tête. Ils sont toujours là dans le
bocage normand.
On est dans la vraie vie et c'est pas la
vie que nous souhaitons bien sûr, mais
c'est voir ça. Et puis il y a un roman
les abeilles grises. C'est un roman
alors j'ai oublié le nom de l'auteur
mais on va le retrouver j'espère. J'ai
pris mon petit papier en antisèche.
Comme j'ai pas mes lunettes, ça va être
génial. Euh toi, tu fais de
l'anticipation, hein.
Il s'appelle Krakov
et c'est l'histoire d'un type qui vit
dans la zone grise du Donbas
et il élève des abeilles. Et ben ce type
là, c'est un être humain et c'est
l'espoir de l'humanité dans la manière
dont il vit. Et c'est un super rendement
parce que il y a cette soif de vivre
dans un rapport d'un homme qui élève des
ruches d'av et qui va d'un bord à
l'autre.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Bouteille à la mer.
Moi, la première fois qu'on s'était vu,
je parlais d'aventure humaine.
Et ben l'espoir des jeunes générations,
c'est que ce mot, cette expression là,
il faut qu'il la traduise dans les faits
et surtout qu'il comprennent que la soif
de vivre,
c'est ça le but d'une vie, la soif de
vivre.
Christian Orbulot, merci.
[Musique]